you reached out 100
oh you are better than me tell me
everything and I met up with her you met
up with her I most certainly did okay
keep going
um and then the boyfriend actually was
so nervous about the whole thing he
ended up saying like can I come and like
be there and
um I said sure I mean this is happening
regardless I just need to understand
what the hell is going on and so I sat
down with her and we did discuss and I
was just like did you know that he was
in a relationship and
um it seemed like that she didn't and
then he drove home and we got out in
front of his house and he was like do
you want to Ty said get out
get out of the right now ah